[Musique]
ainsi ce qui n'est pas de résignation
japonais contrôle à boston
[Musique]
une semaine après la déclaration de
guerre de vladimir poutine à l'ukraine
l'offensive russe touche l'ensemble du
territoire ukrainien comment ce plan
d'invasion at il été organisée et
qu'elle stratégiques l'armée russe est
elle en train de suivre
[Musique]
en ukraine l'armée russe développe une
opération en trois phases la première
phase rapide et surprise a eu lieu le
premier jour et doit créer le choc et
les x selon cette note de l'ifri publié
le 24 février il est écrit que cette
entrée en premier vise la neutralisation
des systèmes de défense aérienne pour
s'assurer la suprématie dans le ciel est
paralysé le commandement ennemi pour
cela les russes ont utilisé des missiles
de croisière de précision très ciblée
cette phrase là ou si vous voulez elle a
effectivement un cas une partie de ses
objectifs mais il semble que les
ukrainiens et bénéficier du temps
nécessaire à la montée en puissance du
dispositif russe pour disperser aussi
une partie de leur capacité ce qui fait
que notamment on a pu
voir une activité d'hélicoptères
d'avions de drones d'ukrainiens alors
qu'on aurait pu s'attendre à ce qu'ils
étaient effectivement ni la deuxième
phase de la stratégie militaire c'est
l'opération terrestre en tant que tel
celle qui se déroule actuellement en
ukraine 4 lignes de front sont
identifiés l'une autour de la capitale
de kiev une autre toujours aux normes et
un peu plus à l'est englobant soumis et
kharkiv deuxième ville du pays une
troisième zone de combat se situe à
l'est aux portes du donbass territoire
contrôlée par les séparatistes pro
russes qui avancent vers marioupol une
ville qui donne accès à la mer d'azov un
front au sud est constitué depuis la
crimée vers personnes ou des combats
acharnés ont lieu pour prendre le
contrôle de cette ville enfin un
cinquième axe de progression des forces
russes pourraient survenir à l'ouest
descendant de la biélorussie le long de
la frontière polonaise l'idée c'est de
montrer qu'il est prêt à lancer l'assaut
massif sur le kf
tout en maintenant les trous ukrainienne
et loyers c'est pour ça qu'il conduit
des attaques du sud vers le nord et du
nord vers le sud de manière à engager le
gros des troupes l'ukrainienne qui font
actuellement face aux provinces
irrédentistes de l'être dans la doctrine
militaire russe actuel li a
traditionnellement dans cette seconde
phase d' attaque un premier échelon
blindés mécanisé qui est envoyé pour
écorner la résistance il est normalement
assez vite renforcés par un deuxième
échelon puis un troisième qui viennent
prendre la relève des soldats et
consolider la percée ça c'est pour la
théorie car en pratique depuis une
semaine l'armée russe voit son schéma un
petit peu perturbé
d'abord parce que le premier coup d'épée
infligé aux forces du craignent and par
le premier échelon russe n'a pas
vraiment eu lieu sur tout le territoire
le jeu de cache cache il intervient
parce que finalement le premier échelon
russe levée si vous voulez rentrer en
contact des forces et craignait or ces
forces et craignait la chaux dispersés
dans des logiques effectivement
territoriale avec le gros de l'armée
ukrainienne qui lui n'est pas encore lu
immédiatement disponible n'est pas
immédiatement l'a ensuite malgré le
caractère incertain des infos divulguée
sur les réseaux sociaux de nombreuses
vidéos montrent les problèmes
d'approvisionnement notamment en
carburant des forces russes et ensuite
un autre souci de taille vient du fait
que l'armée russe est une arme et
d'appeler et les soldats russes a bien
qu'ils combattent non pas des
tchétchènes qui sont quand même d'une
autre culture que la majorité des des
bérus gérer occidentaux mais là c'est
bien des soldats russes de culture
chrétienne qui vont attaquer non pas des
russes mais décelable de culture
également chrétienne donc on voit bien
que pendant combien de temps une arme et
d'appeler à accepter de suivre sans
broncher les oraux de b par petit tous
ces éléments permettent d'expliquer
pourquoi on a eu l'impression d'une
opération un petit peu désynchronise les
premiers jours la question qui se pose
c'est de savoir si cette
désynchronisation elle est accidentelle
entre guillemets au sang chaud voilà le
manque de carburant daisy n'étaient pas
prêts etc etc ou au contraire est-ce
qu'elle est voulue c'est à dire que les
russes pour tamponner
relativement rapidement sur l'arbitré
nien cession ni ben tiens
finalement elle n'est pas là chrétien
profitons-en pour faire une pause
conforter nos positions et puis repartir
cette fois-ci non pas en mode
choisi échelon par échelon mais en
rassemblant l'ensemble sur le territoire
et puis ensuite en basculant notamment
en basculant notamment vers kiev sur ces
images satellites prises non loin de
kiev on voit des colonnes massive de
chars arriver sûrement le deuxième
échelon voire peut-être le troisième
échelon selon joseph henrotin
sidération puis invasion concrète du
pays voilà pour les deux premières
phases du plan d' attaques russes et si
l'objectif est de changer le régime
ukrainien la troisième phase de la
stratégie militaire russe serait alors
l'occupation durable du pays la première
question c'est de savoir si finalement
les russes ont suffisamment de troupes
pour occuper un pays très grande de plus
de 44 millions d'habitants on est même
sur des sur un véritable défi ce qui
pose de recherche la question de savoir
si mais russes dans leur évaluation
préalable s'il ne se sont pas quelque
part autour intoxiqué aux chances dans
les buts de guerre
russe et dans la légitimation dans le
narratif qui accompagne l'offensive
russe on parle du fait que l'ukraine
serait un peuple frère
avec des riffs funky vont accueillir en
libérateurs les russes et donc
évidemment le sous-entendu c'est que
l'occupation va être beaucoup plus
simple
à partir du moment où une partie de la
population adhère alors que vous
cherchez à poser en réalité la situation
ici est beaucoup plus complexe pour
l'instant toujours en phase 2 du plan
d'attaqué et la russie semble en tout
cas être sur la retenue selon de
nombreux observateurs
elle n'a pas encore engagé de combat de
haute intensité et ne semble pas
rechercher activement le combat de
contact et l'armée russe est en
particulier connu lé pour la puissance
de son artillerie pour appeler
probablement des orgues de staline car
thierry qui n'a pas été donné ce volet
il est sûr que l'armée russe peut faire
pleuvoir sur kiev un déluge de but elle
ne veut pas et parce que ce serait
encore ce serait encore évidemment une
étape qui qui accentuerait encore la
chute de la russie qui est déjà qui est
déjà très par vous avez continué dans la
dans la posture exacte du parieur il a
fait un pari il a perdu au départ
jusqu'où je continue à miser pour ne pas
repartir les poches vides 1 cc c'est
exactement ça et l'occident doit
comprendre qu'il ne peut pas repartir
les pauses 8 parce que s'il est il à la
tentation en qu'il peut repartir les
poches vides il va continuer à miser
esprits ça c'est le mirage de la
victoire c'est le mirage de la victoire
qui saisit tous les chefs qui s'engagent
dans une opération militaire